Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, ich hab ja nochmal kurz den Switch getauscht. Jetzt sollte eigentlich alles besser laufen.
Macht er... Wann... Blöcke abt.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 556 vom, was haben wir, 2. Juli 2026 und,
alles läuft stabil.
Ja, die Öffentlichkeit lernt nicht aus, ne? GSMR haben sie jetzt auch gelernt.
Ja, wobei das ja an sich ganz gut funktioniert hat bisher immer so. Ich meine.
Das ist ja.
Ein gut abgehangen Technologie, würde ich sagen. ein bisschen überlastet, aber,
ja.
Bahnausfall lag daran, dass jemand einen Switch getauscht hat,
dann ein Softwarefehler aufgetreten ist und dann nicht das redundante System,
automatisch gewechselt wurde. Also auf das redundante System gewechselt wurde.
Das war an dem, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, war das dem Mittwoch,
der Mittwoch von der Fusion, oder? Es war auf jeden Fall, also,
Push-Nachricht, sämtliche Züge stehen, war jetzt so,
oh.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, sie hatten zwar so ein Failover,
also vielleicht noch mal kurz Kontext, also Bahn,
immerhin war das dann später am Abend, wo sie es gemacht haben,
also nicht tagsüber mal eben das Software-Update gemacht, aber sie haben einen,
Switch ausgetauscht, also ich vermute mal einen Internet-Switch.
Und der hat dann durch ein Fehlverhalten verhindert, dass dieses Failover auch
automatisch durchgeführt werden konnte, was eigentlich da ist.
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen dumm.
Also wenn genau das, was eigentlich verhindern soll, dass es ein Problem gibt,
dann genau dazu führt, dass es ein Problem gibt.
Der Failover-Switch ist sehr wichtig, dass er funktioniert, weil sonst hat er
nämlich keinen Failover.
Ja, genau. Das ist ein bisschen dramatisch.
Aber sie haben es auch tatsächlich relativ schnell wieder hinbekommen.
Sie haben ja dann das Willingssystem manuell in Betrieb genommen und dann lief das alles wieder.
Aber so bundesweiter Bahnausfall, alle Züge stehen.
Einschließlich der S-Bahn.
Alles.
Das ist, sag ich mal, einer der schlechteren Tage auf der Arbeit.
Wie, ach, den Switch sollte ich einbauen? Ja, ich frage mich,
was an diesem Switch dann auch kaputt war. Also das ist schon interessant.
Naja, ich habe ein bisschen Mitleid, muss ich sagen, mit den Mitarbeitern,
weil gut, vielleicht hätten sie ihn irgendwie vorher nochmal testen müssen und
irgendeine Prozedur hat da gefehlt und letztlich gefailt, aber,
ach Gott, immer die arme Bahn, völlig unterfinanziert, politisch komplett ins
Abseits geschoben, ihr habt mein Mitleid.
Immerhin, ich würde sagen, immerhin mal ein neuer Grund, warum die Bahn nicht
kommt. So. Wären wir mal wohl.
Ja, genau.
So, womit fangen wir denn an? Ein bisschen Feedback hatten wir.
Zum Beispiel zu D-E-Mail und dessen offizielles Ausschalten.
Christian legt noch nach. Eure Diskussion über den Zustand der digitalen Verwaltung
in Deutschland hat bei mir schmerzhafte Flashbacks ausgelöst.
Ich war tatsächlich einer dieser gefühlt fünf unerschrockene D-E-Mail-Nutzer in diesem Land.
Spoiler, es war die absolute rechtsverbindlich zertifizierte Vollkatastrophe.
Man schickte damals eine E-Mail an eine Behörde und durfte danach erstmal fünf
Runden das digitale Blogwart-Dasein durchspielen.
Ja, das ist gerade wirklich rechtsverbindlich. Nein, das ist keine normale E-Mail.
Nein, da kommt kein Papier und Dokument nach.
Das ist nicht das moderne Äquivalent zu vorab per Fax.
Wenn man diese formelle Fegefeuer überstanden hatte, ging der eigentliche Systemfehler
erst los. Die E-Mail verpflichtete die Behörde nämlich mitnichten dazu,
ihrerseits elektronisch zu antworten.
Die logische Konsequenz, man halbierte zwar den Postlaufweg hinters Amt,
durfte dann aber zehn Tage auf die analoge Antwort per Schneckenpost warten.
Auf dem gedruckten Brief stand dann ironischerweise das Datum des ursprünglichen D-E-Mail.
Sie haben also taggleich geantwortet, die Antwort aber lieber ausgedruckt,
kuvertiert und zur Post getragen.
Wer glaubt, das neue elektronische Bürger- und Organisationspostfach,
EBO, mache alles besser, irrt die Diskussion.
Ob das jetzt wirklich per Brief sein muss, habe ich zwar nur noch ein Drittel der Fälle.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das EBO über dieselben Kanäle wie das BEA bzw.
BEN ins EGVP einspeist. Jetzt bin ich ein bisschen raus mit den Abkürzungen.
Das ist elektronische Gerichts- und Verwaltungspostfach. Das ist das...
Und sich für die Sachbearbeiter dadurch irgendwie offizieller anfühlt.
Trotzdem muss man die Behörden immer noch durch unangenehmes,
permanentes Nudging dazu zwingen, den digitalen Rückkanal auch zu benutzen.
Meine aktuelle und extrem praktikable Gegenmaßnahme.
Ich schicke den Ämtern und Gerichten nach dem zweiten Mal freundlichen,
bitte nutzen Sie doch auch den elektronischen Rückkanal.
Eingescannte handschriftliche Dokumente als Antwort. mit dem freundlichen Kommentar,
dass sie von mir ab sofort auch nur noch digital nicht durchsuchbare Dokumente
bekommen, solange ich von ihnen Briefposte erhalte.
Und siehe da, plötzlich und wie durch ein administratives Wunder finden sie
auf einmal doch den Knopf, um einen PDF zu verschicken. PDF.
Ach ja. Schlimm. Thorsten hat auch noch was dazu beizutragen.
Thorsten vom E-Government-Podcast. Grüße gehen raus. Hallo zusammen.
Zuerst freue ich mich, dass endlich das totepferd.de mir jetzt endlich in die ewige Ruhe gehen darf.
Dann bin ich sehr besorgt, dass das BMDS das nächste tote Pferd entwickeln lässt.
Die Deutschland-App. Kurz oder kurz Schlapp.
Die Schlapp-App. Dieses Projekt ist schon tot, bevor es überhaupt gestartet
ist. Und die Idee, jetzt alles mit einem magischen KI-Schicht zu lösen, ist selten dämlich.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass die beteiligten Produktmanager sich noch nie mit
der kommunalen Infrastruktur auseinandergesetzt haben.
Sie scheinen noch nicht einmal geprüft zu haben, was es bereits im Funktionieren
gibt. Erstens, Identität per E-ID prüfen.
Warum wird nicht gleich die EU, die Wallet oder wenigstens die Bund-ID eingebaut?
Zweitens, Kommunikation über Wire. Das ist dieser, ja, ich weiß gar nicht.
Der Messenger.
Ja, aber das ist ja, also das ist glaube ich Open Source, aber so ein richtiger
Standard ist es ja nicht, ne?
What the fuck, es gibt bereits eine stehende Kommunikationsinfrastruktur auf
Basis des Matrix-Protokolls, das nennt sich ZAPUK, und,
wird von der FITCO entwickelt, was auch immer das sein mag, und bereitgestellt,
warum muss man auf ein Unternehmen bauen, welches schon mehrfach hin und her
verkauft wurde und man sich sicher sein kann, dass der deutsche Staat weiterhin
die rechtliche Kontrolle darüber hat. Das frage ich mich allerdings auch.
Drittens, Termine bei Behörden buchen. Facepalm hoch 10. Was will die ab denn
erreichen? Sollen die Bürgerinnen wieder ins analoge Amt gehen?
Davon abgesehen gibt es in Deutschland allein 11.000 Kommunen.
Und wenn jede Kommune eine Terminvereinbarung für nur zwei Behörden anbietet,
das wird im Durchschnitt noch nicht einmal ausreichen, dann sind das schon 22.000
Verbindungen, die gemacht werden müssen. Also im Sinne von Anbindungen.
Da kommen dann natürlich noch die Landes- und Bundesbehörden dazu.
Wenn ich das mal ganz grob proinservativ hochrechne, dann sprechen wir sicherlich
von 50.000 anzubindenden Terminvereinbarungen. Ganz zu schweigen davon,
dass nicht alle Behörden die gleichen Systeme benutzen, was dieses Vorhaben noch verschärft.
Viertens, Wohnsitz ummelden. Ist eine kommunal ausgeführte Leistung und befindet
sich gerade bundesweit im Rollout und könnte sehr einfach eingebaut werden,
wenn man die vorhandene Infrastruktur verwendet. Sonst sind es wieder 11.000 Endpoints.
Das könnte der Grund sein, warum sie das als ersten Use Case nehmen.
Dass es da einen bundesweiten Rollout gibt. Dass es da halt einen Standard gibt.
Kindergeld beantragen. Wer will das in einer App machen und vor allem,
wie oft macht man das in seinem Leben?
Zudem wurde gerade das Gesetz geändert, dass man nur noch beim ersten Kind machen
muss und es bei jedem weiteren Kind automatisch passiert. Die nächste Stufe
ist, dass das Kindergeld komplett antraglos ausgezahlt wird.
Eine Lösung in einer App oder als Online-Dienst ist also reine Geldverschwendung.
Unternehmensgründung digital unterstützen, sechster Punkt. Was soll das heißen?
Dazu ist auch das wieder eine Leistung, die in 11.000 Kommunen ausgeführt wird.
Naja, fügt noch an, das Projekt soll einen Prototyp bauen, hat aber bereits,
ein paar wenige Kommunen akquiriert, die an einer Pilotierung teilnehmen.
Was passiert am Ende der Pilotierung? Wird die App wieder gelöscht?
Nimmt man den Bürgerinnen die Funktion wieder weg?
Jedenfalls kann man aus einem Prototyp keine sinnvolle, produktive Software
bauen, zumal dieser Prototyp eher beweisen soll, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
By the way wird es nicht. Nach der Pilotierung soll dann eine richtige Ausschreibung
erfolgen, welches Unternehmen bindet sich an einen gruden Prototyp zur Weiterentwicklung ans Bein.
Es ist also schon vorprogrammiert, dass Telekom und SAP auch die Ausschreibung
für den Produktivbetrieb gewinnen werden.
Gibt es niemanden in diesem BMDS, der mal die Bürgerinnen fragt,
was sie wirklich brauchen oder mal schaut, was der Bund und die Länder bereits
bezahlen und betreiben, ohne alles zum zehnten Mal zu erfinden.
Ich könnte mich noch viel mehr aufregen, aber ich muss auf meinen Blutdruck
achten und gehe jetzt erstmal zwei bis drei Stunden zum Yoga,
um wieder runter zu kommen.
Wir hören deinen Schmerz, Thorsten.
Dann hatten wir recht viele Kommentare zum KI-Blog in der letzten Sendung,
die ich mal von einer KI habe zusammenfassen lassen.
Classy. Classy.
Also erstmal gab es ein paar Kommentare, die betrachte ich als disqualifiziert,
die waren so ein bisschen was, das ging dann so in die Richtung,
ja was uns aber als Mensch ausmacht und was eigentlich die Intelligenz ist.
Ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher, dass ich die ganze Zeit nur von Produktivität
gesprochen habe und nicht von,
menschlicher Überlegenheit oder Intelligenz oder sonstigen, sondern einfach
nur, was man mit diesen Systemen wie viel schneller machen kann. Und.
Dass dieser Effekt, dieser wie viel effektiver man bestimmte Dinge damit erledigen
kann, dass dieser Produktivitätsgewinn nicht im Verhältnis steht zu den Preisen,
die man dafür aktuell zahlt.
Darauf, jetzt mal die Kommentare, die inhaltlich, denke ich,
zutreffend sind, die qualifiziert sind, die Wirtschaftsanalyse,
wird zu eng gedacht, also dass ich quasi einen KI-bedingten Wirtschaftskollaps.
Sehe als möglicher Effekt.
Wird kritisiert, dass es einen westlich-akademischen Bias gäbe.
Handwerk, Bau, Pflege, Landwirtschaft, Müll, Forst.
Also das, was eine Gesellschaft tatsächlich zum Leben braucht,
ist ja gar nicht durch eine KI ersetzbar.
Das wäre also nur der reiche Dienstleistungssektor, auf den das hier zutrifft,
was ich mit den KI-Effekten gesagt habe.
Würde ich nur teilweise zustimmen,
Weil mein Argument ja eigentlich noch ein größeres ist, dass nämlich,
wenn an zu vielen Sektoren eine
Disruption stattfindet, halt das Wirtschaftssystem aus den Fugen gerät.
Und ja, die KI wird nicht die wunderbaren handwerklichen Leistungen vollbringen können.
Das werden wir Menschen dann noch machen müssen. Wir sind dann quasi,
also die Überlegenheit unserer Hände, bis es jemandem gelingt,
bessere Hände für Roboter zu bauen, wird uns noch ein bisschen in Lohn und Brot halten.
Aber irgendwo muss das ganze Geld ja auch herkommen. Insofern würde ich da schon
einen massiven Effekt sehen, wenn es so weiter ginge.
Was ich nicht sage, was unbedingt notwendigerweise passiert.
Es gibt ja noch den anderen Effekt, den habe ich auch benannt,
wenn die Produktivitätsversprechen, in die da gerade investiert wird,
sich nicht bewahrheiten,
dann haben wir eine Blase und auch dann haben wir Probleme für Baupflege,
Landwirtschaft, Forst, Handwerk und so weiter.
Da gab es übrigens jetzt auch gerade eine recht gut,
oder recht breit reziprierte Einlassung der Bank für den internationalen Zahlungsausgleich,
also Bank for International Settlement, also die Bank zwischen den Banken.
Die bilden quasi das dann noch ab. und die sagen, okay, hier einfach,
wenn wir uns anschauen, wie viel Geld in diese Investitionen,
geschoben wird, dass sie also sagen, man kann eigentlich sich nicht vorstellen,
dass hier all diesen Investitionen ein angemessener Return noch entgegensteht.
Die fünf größten Hyperscaler werden voraussichtlich eine Billion US-Dollar für
KI-bezogene Investitionen ausgeben.
Also mit anderen Worten, eine Billion US-Dollar Investitionen nicht,
da kriegen wir Geld für zurück, sondern da kaufen wir etwas in Hoffnung auf
weiteren Profit oder wir geben Geld aus.
Und das haben sie natürlich, das Geld leihen sie sich und die Verpflichtungen,
die sie damit eingehen, überschreiten ihre Gewinne und den freien Cashflow.
Also sie verschulden sich in sehr großem Ausmaß an Anleihenmärkten für weiteres
Kapital und dieses Geld schulden sie, das haben sie nicht.
Und der Wettbewerb läuft mit hoher Intensität, weshalb die Unternehmen Gefahr
laufe, zu viele Ressourcen in diese Projekte mit der ungewissen Rendite zu stecken,
was wiederum bedeutet, dass sie potenziell dieses Geld nicht zurückzahlen können.
Einzelne oder auch alle.
Und dieser Boom könnte dann eben, also weil die Rendite ungewiss ist und weil,
die Ausgaben steigen, sinkt aber auch die Möglichkeit, damit überhaupt nochmal
irgendwann Gewinne zu machen.
Also selbst wenn, sagen wir mal, du am Ende die Mega-KI hast und die schafft
das, quasi unglaubliche Gewinne einzufahren,
hast du eventuell trotzdem immer noch die Möglichkeit, das Risiko,
dass du die nicht mehr einfährst, weil du trotzdem überschuldet bist.
Dann sagen sie, wir stoßen an die Engpässe bei Stromhalbleiter-Netzwerkausrüstung.
Das haben wir zum Beispiel letzte Woche noch gar nicht behandelt.
Speichermedien und Arbeitsspeicher ist ausverkauft. die Preise sind so hoch
gestiegen, dass Apple-Rechner auf einmal attraktiv wurden, wo der RAM traditionell zu,
fürchterlich überbepreist ist,
und das auf einmal machte das Sinn, sich Apple-Rechner zu kaufen,
bis dann Apple auch wie angekündigt jetzt die Preise massiv also zwischen 20
und 60% erhöht hat, je nach Produkt oder so,
um da die Marge zu schonen.
Wir müssen ja die Marge pflegen.
Und alles außer iPhones ist sozusagen teuer geworden. Die iPhones sind wahrscheinlich erst im Herbst.
Also klar, das Blasenrisiko wird gerade allenthalben diskutiert und ist auch,
völlig klar. Ich denke, das deckt sich aber eben mit meiner Sache,
es kann so nicht weitergehen, die Preise müssen anziehen.
Dann sagt der Florian, was ich sehr wichtig finde, was ich auch in der letzten
Sendung nicht ausreichend betont hatte, die Openweight-Modelle,
also die frei betreibbaren,
sind irgendwas zwischen 6 und 18
Monate zurück hinter den großen Foundation-Modellen und lokal gut genug.
Ja und das sagt er auch, das ist natürlich, das treibt diese Entwicklung weiter
und weil es hinten genauso gut wieder was abschneidet, was du überhaupt nochmal
remonetarisieren kannst.
Also du, angenommen es wäre so, dass jetzt, keine Ahnung,
in 18 Monaten ist das, was dir Anthropic oder OpenAI gerade als das allergeilste
verkaufen, ja, mit hohen Usage-Limits oder hohen Preisen,
wäre in, sagen wir mal im Schnitt in anderthalb Jahren frei verfügbar für alle.
Kannst du auf deinem Mac Mini, wenn du einen noch bekommen hast, betreiben, ja.
Dann wäre ja quasi, dann haben die ja auch nur ungefähr zwölf Monate Amortisationszeit
auf so ein Modell, während diese Edge, die meisten Leute diese Edge ja auch
gar nicht brauchen. Ja, das kommt dann irgendwie zu einem Ende.
Kann nicht exponentiell so weiter wachsen. Und dann sagt er eben,
diese Blase würde einfach nur noch viel größer dadurch. ich ein richtiges, wichtiges Argument.
Dann wird natürlich gesagt, okay, was ist denn mit einer globalen KI-Kontrolle?
Es gibt kaum ernsthafte Diskussionsbeiträge zur Kontrolle,
mal das Ganze international einzudämmen. Ja, ich glaube halt,
dass es dadurch, dass die, dass hier auch Weltmächte im Wettkampf um Weltmacht
sind, genau das nicht passiert.
Also China wird sich da auf jeden Fall nicht groß regulieren lassen.
Ja, macht das doch. Reguliert euch mal. Aber das ist genau das,
was wir auch versucht haben, ein bisschen zu schildern.
Aber dann gibt es noch einen wichtigen Punkt, den ich letztes Mal denke ich
auch unterbelichtet habe.
Markus sagt, eigentlich profitiert gerade niemand außer Anlegern und KI-Forschern.
Es ist nichts günstiger geworden, stattdessen teurer, die Nutzung wird aufgezwungen,
und nicht ausgesucht, eher Peer-Pressure, auch in den Konzernen,
die jetzt sagen, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt was mit KI machen, das stimmt auch.
Und sagt, das gibt aber natürlich sozialen Sprengstoffungleichverteilung und
Manipulationsrisiken.
Das sehe ich auch und da gibt es einen wunderschönen Begriff,
den ich in Vorträgen sehr häufig zitiere.
Und zwar ist das das Produktivitätsparadoxon.
Vom Nobelpreisträger für Ökonomie, glaube ich, Solo.
Oje. Äh.
Ich kann es besser erklären als die Leute.
Die Leute benennen. Der hat im Prinzip so etwas gesagt wie,
Computer finden sich überall, außer in den Produktivitätsstatistiken.
Und es gibt quasi, sagt quasi die Produktivitätsgewinne, also wir haben diesen
offensichtlich unglaublich effizienten Computer.
Und es ist augenscheinlich völlig klar, dass sich damit unglaubliche Effizienzen realisieren lassen,
wir aber weder in den Unternehmen noch in
den Volkswirtschaften diesen Produktivitätszuwachs auch realisiert sehen.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Digitalisierung findet zwar statt,
aber sie bleibt sehr hinter den Erwartungen zurück.
Und als ich das zum ersten Mal in einem Vortrag auch referenziert habe, genau, Robert Solo,
hat das gesagt, der Computer finden
sich überall außer den Produktivitätsstatistiken. Da hatte mir dann...
Der Holger Schmidt, genau, von der FAZ, widersprochen und sagte,
klar findet sich das in den Produktivitätsstatistiken, guckt ihr mal an,
was Meta, Amazon und so weiter umsetzen.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja klar, aber dann schaut ihr den Rest der US-Wirtschaft
an, die stagniert halt seit 30, 40 Jahren oder so.
Und also irgendwie schafft die Menschheit es.
Diese Digitalisierungsproduktivitätsgewinne irgendwie auszubremsen.
Interessante These, weil vor allem das, was Markus ja auch sagt,
der Kostennutzen für die Normalbürger findet halt nicht statt.
Das war das, was ich so ein bisschen angesprochen hatte mit einer Automatisierungsdividende.
Und dann gab es noch einen, finde ich, wichtigen Punkt, den ich unterbelichtet hatte.
Menschen verlernen jetzt. Man liest nichts mehr über 100 Wörter,
die halluzinierten Quellenangaben werden nicht geprüft und wir steuern im Prinzip
in Richtung einer Idiocracy.
Auch das bilde ich mir ein schon länger um mich herum zu beobachten das ist,
nicht neu durch KI sozusagen.
Und das ist aber natürlich auch das finde ich eine und hier stelle ich nur die
philosophische Frage angenommen diese Technologie würde,
ungefähr einen wichtigen Einfluss in der Gesellschaft bekommen.
Und angenommen, die Gesellschaft würde irgendwie grob stabil bleiben,
das würde irgendwie so, wir kriegen die Kurve irgendwie.
Platz keine Blase oder die Blase platzt und 20 Jahre später ist dann halt der Boom da, wie es,
beispielsweise bei der Dotcom-Blase durchaus war. Oder 10 Jahre später hat sich
das dann x-fach realisiert. Also Dotcom-Blase, großes Thema,
da hatten wir alle, wenn ich damals ein Portfolio gehabt hätte,
wäre ich traurig gewesen. Da haben wir viel Federn gelassen.
Aber das, was damals an Hoffnungen diese Blase entfacht hat,
hat sich Jahrzehnt später oder was,
oder vielleicht auch ungefähr Jahrzehnt später, x-fach realisiert.
Nur nicht bei den Unternehmen, in die investiert worden war.
Das Geld war jetzt erstmal weg.
Oder das war richtig weg. War aber auch nie da, waren ja nur Bewertungen von Unternehmen.
Ich sag nur Gartner Hype Curve.
Oder Hype Cycle. Das ist ja so der Klassiker, diese Kurve, die erstmal total nach oben ausschlägt.
Dann kommt das Tal der Ernüchterung und dann kommt das Plateau. der...
Genau, und später wird das dann realisiert. Das gilt jetzt nicht unbedingt für
alles, also das gilt sozusagen nur für die richtigen Technologien.
Ich glaube, bei Blockchain sieht die Kurve ein bisschen anders aus.
Abwarten, da kommt nochmal wieder.
Da wird bestimmt. Ist ja erst 15 Jahre her.
Aber angenommen, das tritt ein und wir sind dann auf dem Plateau der Produktivität,
dann stellt sich ja trotzdem und die Frage wirklich stelle ich nur offen,
wie bildest du jetzt noch Kinder in der Schule aus,
ja gute, solide Teile dieser Gesellschaft zu sein, ja, weil die müssen ja mit
dieser neuen Technologie umgehen, die stehen und sie müssen ja auch kompetent damit umgehen,
und gleichzeitig musst du irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass sie ja auch noch selber
fit werden, ja, und irgendwie noch selber mitdenken können, was natürlich durch
diese Technologie zunehmend,
müßig wird, selber zu denken, ja.
Und das ist schwierig, weil dann atrophiert der Denkmuskel, ja und da da hast
du dann quasi auch diese Selbstverstärkung, dann könnte wirklich irgendwann
wird nicht die KI übermächtig, sondern die Menschheit unterdumm ja,
ich bin ja nur rum, aber ich finde es gar nicht so blöd, dass wir also ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass ein Schulsystem, das auf irgendwie auswendig lernen,
Textanalyse und solchen Dingen basiert,
Menschen,
Und gut vorbereitet auf 20 Jahre spätere Gesellschaft, dort.
Ein wichtiges, solides Mitglied zu sein.
Ja, das Betrugspotenzial in der Schule ist derzeit einfach viel zu hoch.
Und das wird halt auch ausgenutzt, weil das machen natürlich alle Schüler.
Und das Betrugspotenzial ist hoch, gut, und jetzt könnte man sagen,
okay, du hast eine ubiquitäre,
Technologie, die steht allen zur Verfügung und die Aufgabe, jetzt könnte man
sagen, einerseits, okay, die Schule muss verhindern, dass die Schülerinnen diese
Technologie nutzen bei der Lösung ihrer Aufgaben, weil die sollen selber denken,
wir müssen den Denkmuskel trainieren,
das ist die intuitiv naheliegende Konsequenz.
Du könntest aber auch sagen, naja, wenn das jetzt schon Kinder sind,
die diese Technologie jetzt schon haben, wenn die in 15 Jahren irgendwo noch einen produktiven,
irgendwie ein wertvoller Beitrag Teil einer Gesellschaft sein sollen,
dann können wir doch nicht diese Technologie jetzt von ihnen fernhalten.
In der Hoffnung, dass wenn wir sie jetzt irgendwie Latein lernen lassen oder
so, dass sie dann bessere,
dass wir dann in eine bessere Gesellschaft steuern. Und ich würde sagen,
mit dem Internet haben wir es auf jeden Fall falsch gemacht.
Die Maßgabe lasst uns die Existenz des Internets vor den Kindern so lange wie
möglich verheimlichen.
Das hat nicht dazu geführt, dass wir jetzt medienkompetente Spitzenkräfte und
eine gesunde Gesellschaft haben.
Die Frage müssen sich andere stellen, zum Glück.
Also ich hatte ja so einen Technologiewandel auch schon mal in der Schule,
noch irgendwie zu meinen Zeiten.
Was denn?
Taschenrechner.
Ja.
Und das war genau dieselbe Diskussion. Ja, wenn wir jetzt Taschenrechner in
der Schule haben, dann lernen die Kinder ja nicht mehr richtig rechnen.
Ja, weil du musst ja irgendwie dein Plus und dein Minus und dein Mal und dein
Geteilt vor allem auch irgendwie handschriftlich mal machen,
weil sonst lernt man ja die Grundrechenarten nicht so richtig.
Und auch wenn ich das generell sehr unterstütze, diese Sichtweise,
ja, also das selbstverständlich lernt man Dinge immer noch viel besser,
umso grundlegender man sie sicher arbeitet und das ist,
ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt eher auch eine individuelle Entscheidung, ja, weil…,
Wenn man Wert auf sein eigenes Lernen legt, dann hat man immer Vorteile,
wenn man das eben so organisiert, aber it's not for everybody.
Und heutzutage ist der Taschenrechner auch im Matheunterricht eigentlich eine
vollkommen normale Geschichte.
Weil… Weil die Aufgaben, die du kriegst, halt nicht mehr, also du musst halt
die richtige, der Taschenrechner hat mehr Knöpfe und du musst die richtige Taste finden.
Also ich habe das nicht so richtig, ich habe diese Taschenrechner-Zeit,
war dann eben auch nicht mehr meine Zeit, sondern es war eben noch so die manuelle,
aber die Diskussion darum war natürlich genau das Gleiche.
Auch wenn ich natürlich schon heimlich irgendwie so einen Pock-Computer in der
Tasche hatte oder das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Und genauso ist es jetzt so ein bisschen auch mit AI. Also man muss natürlich,
das Lernen muss da hinterfragen und man muss sich da neue Antworten machen und
ohnehin, glaube ich, würde es zumindest es dem deutschen,
Schulmodell ohnehin ganz gut tun, mehr auf orale Wissensvermittlungen und Vorträge und,
mündliche Diskussionen zu setzen, als,
diese gnadenlose Verifizierbarkeit von Schrift sozusagen zu machen.
Man muss sich nichts vormachen. In Prüfungen haben die Kids ein Zweit-Smartphone
dabei und benutzen das in Prüfungen, um irgendwie ihre Matheaufgaben zu lösen.
Ja, die geben einfach ihr Smartphone vom letzten Jahr bei der Lehrerin ab.
Genau. Genau so sieht's aus.
Ich habe iPhone 15.
Ich hab auch schon von Klassen gehört, wo alle das getan haben in einer Matheprüfung,
bis auf eine, die wirklich das alles erlernt hat.
Ja, und die schulschlechteste jetzt.
Und dann sozusagen, die anderen hatten alle eine Eins und sie hatte eine Zwei und dann war,
Die Problematik, das kannst du ja noch nicht mal petzen. Bist du ja sozusagen noch pein durch.
Ja, da sind die Lehrer noch nicht so ganz so aware.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Herausforderungen. Ich meine, als ich dann irgendwann,
als ich als Kind erfuhr, dass dann die Großen in der Schule,
die dürfen mit Taschenrechnern, habe ich gesagt, ja geil, ist ja lächerlich.
Aber als ich dann irgendwann mal im Physik-Elkada saß und die Scheiße ausrechnen
musste, da war der Taschenrechner nun wirklich die kleinste Hilfe.
Und das wäre ja wirklich eine feine Sache.
Weil der Weg ist halt wichtig, den muss man lernen. Das Blöde nur bei der AI
ist, dass sie den Weg auch noch haben.
Die legt dir einen Weg plausibel dar.
Stimmt der? Who knows?
Und ansonsten, naja, also unterbelichtete Themen in der letzten Sendung.
Ja, quasi diese ganze Faschismus Ebene, Zentralisierung von Macht,
Demokratie Verächtlichmachung von den wenigen Leuten, in deren Händen das ist.
Ökologische Themen haben wir komplett weggelassen.
Bubble haben wir erwähnt. Zentralisierung, riesiges Problem.
Und kombiniert aber mit, die Openweight Modelle ziehen nach und könnten dieser
Zentralisierung ein Gegengewicht bieten.
Aber, wenn ich mir anschaue, dieser gesamte Outsourcing-Gedanke und as a service und so weiter.
Das Betrieb einer eigenen IT und so.
Den Trick haben sie ja schon mal mit uns gemacht. Deswegen liegt ja jetzt gerade
alles in der Cloud und nicht auf unseren Clustern.
Qualität der Ergebnisse, da waren dann auch einige Leute enttäuscht,
dass ich auch gute Ergebnisse mit KI beobachte, weil das ist ja,
eine religiöse Sparte inzwischen, dass alles, was eine KI macht,
auf jeden Fall Slop ist. Ja, genau.
Das ist genauso eine religiöse Sparte wie die, die sagt, alles was die KI macht,
Release to Production.
Das sind glaube ich beides,
also beides ist für mich einfach ein Marker,
von religiösem Eifer. Insbesondere die Leute, die sagen, dass alles,
was eine KI macht, schlecht ist. Die haben relativ wenig Erfahrung darin, mit einer zu arbeiten.
Während die, die sagen, alles, was eine KI macht, ist gut, die scheinen genauso
wenig Erfahrung zu haben, wenn eine KI wirklich mal was Gutes hinzukriegen.
Weil es ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Und ja, ist eine insgesamt böse Entwicklung, die wir da sehen.
Hatte ich ja zum Beispiel auch in der Funfacts-Folge versucht darzustellen,
dass Datenzentralisierung, KI.
Möglichkeiten, es geht ja nicht nur darum, das Modell zu haben, sondern eben auch die,
Ressourcen und die Produktionsmittel, alle diese Daten analysieren zu können,
deine KI auf was auch immer laufen zu lassen, alle diese Daten zu bekommen,
ist das andere so große Problem, das viel größere eigentlich an dieser Technologie.
Wenn du sagst, okay, die Zukunft ist, jeder hat so seine sein Pocket-KI,
ja, nicht mehr den TI, Pocket Calculator, sondern den AI,
dann wäre das ja noch nicht mal, also wäre es nur halb so schlimm,
wie wenn wir sagen, okay, es gibt zwei, drei Hyperscaler, die sich durchgesetzt
haben, bei denen alle Daten sind und die Modelle sind von mir aus,
sind die nur 18 Monate den anderen voraus, die haben aber nun mal alle Daten,
Um damit zu arbeiten, um darauf zu lernen, um sonst was und es gibt einfach nichts anderes mehr.
Es gibt keine Mittel mehr, die du hättest, damit zu konkurrieren,
weil du halt eben alles abgegeben hast.
Und Fun Fact am Rande, die Hacker-Konferenz HOPE findet irgendwie Anfang August
in New York statt, Hackers on Planet Earth, die haben zu ihrer Konferenz Vertreter
von eigentlich allen großen KI-Unternehmen eingeladen und haben gesagt,
können wir mal offenen Dialog machen.
Und in jedem einzelnen Fall verloren die Firmenvertreter das Interesse,
als sie erfuhren, dass der Vortrag keine unwidersprochene Verkaufspräsentation
sein würde, sondern dass da ein paar Hacker sitzen, die auch kritische Fragen stellen.
Da haben die gesagt, nö, nö. Ach so.
Jetzt mal. Wo kommen wir denn hin?
Und das ist natürlich schon auch durchaus irre, dass dann irgendwie von den
wenigen Milliardären, von diese wenigen Systeme, die von irgendwelchen Milliardären
gebastelt werden, die sich sogar,
einer offenen technischen Diskussion verweigern.
OpenAI, Anthropic, Meta, Google, Microsoft X, Nvidia,
alle kein Bock.
Ja, das muss jetzt alles erstmal, Die sind einfach gewohnt, überall gefeiert
zu werden, als die Verkünder der Frohen Botschaft.
Aber das ist jetzt auch so nichts Neues. Also ich meine, da kannst du auch die
ganzen anderen Hypes der letzten Jahre zusammenfegen, da haben sie sich eigentlich
auch genauso verhalten.
Machen dann einfach ihre eigene Konferenz, ja. Genau. Alright,
kommen wir jetzt soviel zur nochmal Gesamtergänzung des thematischen oder des
perspektivischen Ausschnitts aus der letzten Sendung.
Durch die vielen Kommentare. Für alle vielen Dank.
Wir haben eine sehr schlechte Nachricht, die wir behandeln müssen.
Und zwar hat der Koalitionsausschuss ja gerade getagt und eine Reihe an Entscheidungen
getroffen, die sie da jetzt auch veröffentlicht haben und jetzt diskutiert werden.
Und das ist ein relativ zwölfseitiges Dokument oder so, wo sie sagen,
keine Ahnung, Rente, wie sie jetzt Deutschland ist, ist alles wieder gut.
Und dann gibt es Punkt 32, wo sie sagen,
wir werden das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz unter Wahrung des Rechts auf den
Zugang zu amtlichen Informationen und in Abstimmung mit dem BFDI weiterentwickeln,
und den aktuellen Herausforderungen anpassen.
Ihr erinnert euch, dass schon bei der Diskussion des Koalitionsvertrages damals
Philipp Amthor versucht hatte, ja, Informationsfreiesgesetz,
das können wir doch mal ersetzen, da haben wir doch was Besseres, da können wir so... Ähm.
Jetzt, und das ist dann gescheitert an dem Protest und jetzt kommt aber quasi
der Koalitionsausschuss, da sitzen ja CDU und SPD schon zusammen und entscheiden
jetzt ihren Koalitionsvertrag,
zu brechen,
denn im Koalitionsvertrag steht, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in der bisherigen
Form wollen wir mit einem Mehrwert für Bürgerinnen und Bürger und Verwaltung
reformieren. So, was machen sie jetzt?
Also wie soll dieser Mehrwert aussehen? Auskunftsrechte,
nur noch für natürliche Personen, die ein berechtigtes Interesse an einer Auskunft
haben und diese Auskunft nicht durch andere Regeln erreichen können.
Dabei prüfen wir, also nur noch Personen, nur noch mit berechtigtem Interesse,
nur noch wenn es keinen anderen Weg gibt.
Dabei prüfen wir, ob der Kreis der betreffenden Personen auf in Deutschland
lebende Deutsche und Unionsbürger beschränkt ist. Das heißt Ausweiskontrolle und so weiter.
Wir wollen unsere Beschäftigungen vor Anfeindungen und Drohungen schützen,
indem wir die Namen der Mitarbeitenden schwärzen.
In Zeiten einer komplexen Bedrohungslage von innen und außen wollen wir die
staatliche Resilienz erhöhen und dem besonderen Schutzbedarf bestimmter Bereiche
wie dem der kritischen Infrastruktur, Spionage, Abwehr, Terrorismusbekämpfung
und auch der wissenschaftlichen Forschung stärker Rechnung tragen.
Mit anderen Worten, mehr Gründe, Informationsfreiheitsanfragen abzulehnen.
Die IFG-Gebühren werden wir im Einklang mit dem Kostendeckungsprinzip anpassen.
Mit anderen Worten, wird teurer.
So, jetzt schauen wir das mal an. Also anfragen nur noch mit berechtigtem Interesse.
Und du musst sagen, dass du persönlich einen besonderen Anspruch auf diese Information hast.
Damit sind fast alle Anfragen, die stattfinden, nicht mehr möglich.
Also sowas wie hier, wir wollen mal diese Signal-Messenger-Kommunikation. Egal.
Wenn man einfach das Gefühl hat, da stimmt was nicht und man will da mal schauen.
Da kommt dann als erstes die Antwort.
Kein berechtigtes Interesse.
Was haben Sie denn damit zu tun?
Als erstes kommt die Ausweis, zeige ich mal Ausweis.
Genau.
Bist du überhaupt Passteutscher?
Und das wird ganz schön teuer.
Das, was Frag den Staat macht,
Deutsche Umwelthilfe, Amnesty International, die dürfen dann keine Anfragen
mehr stellen, weil sie keine natürlichen Personen sind.
Juristischen Personen werden Anfragen untersagt und auch Pressevertreter können
dann nicht mehr so einfach IFG-Anfragen stellen.
Bei jeder Anfrage musst du Staatsangehörigkeit nachweisen und wenn wir hier,
wir wollen unsere Leute vor Anfeindungen schützen, schön und gut, aber,
zu diesem Transparenz-Gedanken gehört ja auch, dass du erkennen können musst,
wer für behördliche Entscheidungen verantwortlich ist.
Ja, also damit du Korruptionen aufdecken kannst und so weiter und das wäre eben
bei einer Schwärzung von allen Namen,
hier die Idee die Gebührendeckel ist aktuell auf 500 Euro,
und wenn sie jetzt sagen, kostet ein Deckungsprinzip dann sagen sie halt,
na die Anfrage das zu beantworten ist ganz schön teuer eine Woche dran gearbeitet
wenn du bis hierhin gekommen bist, ja, mit deinem Pass und dem Berechtigungs-Wie
konnten dir noch nicht mal dein berechtigtes Interesse, wenn du es bis hierhin gekommen,
dann wird es jetzt auch ich nehme mal ganz kurz hier Taschenrechner,
und rechne mal eben aus Hat der Ministerpräsident.
Eine Woche dran gearbeitet?
Was die verdienen irgendwie und,
dann natürlich noch mehr Gründe zur Ablehnung das ist wirklich das wäre also
das ist die Abschaffung der Informationsfreiheit und das wäre das,
Ende von ja tatsächlich sowas wie fragt den Staat, das wäre das Ende davon,
dass wir hier eine transparente,
eine transparente Möglichkeiten der Transparenz haben, dass die Tätigkeiten
der Regierungen und Behörden zu kontrollieren.
Und nochmal, das alles machen diese Leute,
Lars Klingbeil, Bärbel Baas, Friedrich Merz, Markus Söder, Alexander Dobrindt und Jens Spahn,
in einer Zeit, wo wir gerade uns darauf vorbereiten müssen, dass eine,
nächstes Thema, verfassungsfeindliche Partei,
in einzelnen Ländern an Regierungsmacht kommt.
Du kannst dir gar nicht, also mir ist, also wie, weißt du?
Aber du hast ja einen Satz weggelassen. Sie sagen, wir werden das komplizierte
IFG für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger verständlicher und transparenter machen.
Indem wir alles schwärzen.
Ja, indem die nicht mehr so viele Informationen kriegen.
Also da sind hier so viel Newspeak drin, das ist schon wirklich erschreckend.
Und das ist, einfach mal eine Absage an Transparenz, nichts anderes.
Da ist überhaupt nichts transparenter und es ist halt auch im Wesentlichen ein
Zeichen dafür, dass FragDen Staat wohl eine ganze Menge bewirkt.
Also das scheint zu gut zu funktionieren so sehr, dass es den Apparat stört,
weil ich muss auch mal jetzt die Gegenfrage stellen, was ist denn eigentlich das Problem?
Also ich meine, ja, aktuelle Herausforderungen anpassen. Damit meinen sie natürlich,
wir wollen nicht über alles Auskunft geben und sagen wir mal,
bei kritischer Infrastruktur kann man ja vielleicht auch nochmal eine Diskussion drüber führen.
Aber Terrorismusbekämpfung ist halt so ein bisschen allgemein.
Ich frage mich, was sind eigentlich die Beispiele, wo hier mal wirklich was aus dem Ruder läuft?
Weil da sehe ich ja ehrlich gesagt, also würde mir jetzt noch nicht mal irgendein Fall einfallen.
Es gibt ein Beispiel, wo man, also die AfD hat systematisch Informationen über
kritische Infrastrukturen in Deutschland abgefragt.
Es gab,
die Frage, warum die AfD sich denn, und zwar systematisch, dafür interessiert
und ob die eventuell die Liste der Fragen nicht vielleicht von Russland bekommen hat.
Ähm naja, selber haben sie es nie ausgedacht und da ist jetzt irgendwie, also das,
Und da wurde dann darüber diskutiert, dass das eine potenzielle Gefahr für die
nationale Sicherheit oder eben für kritische Infrastrukturen darstellt.
Daher kam dann dieser Gedanke,
wenn es kritische Infrastrukturen betrifft, dann kein IFG.
Da kommt diese Idee her.
Wenn du dann aber schaust, wenn du versuchst herauszufinden,
was ist denn eine kritische Infrastruktur, da gibt es halt keine rechtssichere
Festlegung, was das ist.
In Berlin wurde das versucht.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie das ausgegangen ist oder ob das schon ausgegangen ist.
Aber die Schwelle kritische Infrastruktur, die wird eher per Verordnung oder
so festgelegt. Ich kenne das grob.
Durch die IT-Sicherheitsgesetze 1 und 2, wo ja dann vor allem das 1,
was für kritische Infrastrukturen galt.
Und dann wurde halt gesagt, was ist denn jetzt eine kritische Infrastruktur?
Und kritische Infrastruktur kann alles sein. Also Finanzwesen, Verkehr, Logistik,
Paketversand, Gas, Wasser, Scheiße, Internet wahrscheinlich nicht. Ja, aber,
das ist sehr, sehr wobbly und dann haben sie nachher per Verordnung dann definiert,
kritische Infrastruktur bist du, wenn du E-Mail-Provider oder Internet-Provider
für so und so viele bist. Oder Wasserversorger für so und so viele.
Und das kannst du dann wiederum, das ist nicht gesetzlich geregelt,
insofern kannst du sehr schnell, problemlos alles Mögliche zu einer kritischen
Infrastruktur erklären.
Ja, also das ist schon wirklich irre.
Getrieben. Also fragt den Staat, hat er jetzt inzwischen auch eine Pressemitteilung zu.
Wer hat Probleme mit dem IFG? So, Jens Spahn? Kein Fan.
Kein Fan. Seine ganzen Kumpeleien und Maskendeals und was, diese ganze,
also dieses ganze, Was ja wirklich ein sehr, sehr schlechtes Bild auf eine Demokratie
wirft, wenn da ein Mensch sich derart gebahrt, der das Vertrauen der Wählerinnen
und Wähler genossen hat.
Kein Fan. Amthor hatte das ja quasi anfänglich versucht, quasi zur Diskussion
des Koalitionsvertrages.
Auch kein Fan, weil der seine Augustus Intelligence Korruption,
nee man sagt ja Interessenkonflikt, ja.
Es ist ja ein Interessenkonflikt, wenn du Unternehmenseigner bist,
Anteilseigner von einem Unternehmen, fürs Nichtstun,
und dann irgendwie versuchst mit deinem Bundestagsabgeordneten Briefpapier Terminchen
klar zu machen mit der Kanzlerin für das Unternehmen.
Das ist ja nicht Korruption, das ist nur ein nicht dargelegter Interessenkonflikt.
Klar, wissen wir und ich komme da immer durcheinander, da muss ich mich jetzt
auch entschuldigen das ist,
ja oder wenn du da irgendwie 5 Millionen anwesend mit Nullzinskrediten von ausgerechnet
den Banken kriegst, die du regulierst oder so das ist das ist,
lupenreine Demokraten sind das ja und die haben natürlich alle gar keinen also
da sitzen sie dann alle zusammen, ne,
Und,
Franziska Giffey musste zurücktreten. Das waren auch alles Informationsfreiheitsanfragen,
die da zugegangen sind. Katharina Reiche.
Wo man sich ja wundert, wo die ihre politischen Visionen denn so her hat.
Da ist noch einiges zu holen, würde ich sagen.
Da gibt es auch sehr viel Verbindungen, wo sie dann auf irgendwelchen Privatterminen,
als eure Exzellenz auftritt, also quasi ihr Amt missbraucht in privaten Wirtschaftstreffen,
wo dann zufällig genau die Themen beschäftigt.
Also, es ist Irrsinn.
Das macht richtig schlechte Laune und das müssen wir unter allen,
also das ist wirklich übel, dass ein Frontalangriff nicht unbedingt gestoppt werden.
Also, ja, da fällt mir auch wenig zu ein. Das ist also allein schon,
also die Beschränkung auf natürliche Personen, das ist schon ein Skandal und
diese berechtigte Interesse, das setzt dem Ganzen ja noch die Krone auf.
Also eigentlich setzt alles hier die Krone auf und dann auch noch mehr Geld nehmen.
Also mit anderen Worten, wir wollen alles dafür tun, dass es gar nicht erst
zu einer Anfrage kommt. Das ist eigentlich die Kernaussage und das alles transparenter,
zu verkaufen ist einfach nur schäbig.
Es ist schäbig und du fragst dich ja wirklich,
welche politische Weitsicht hast du,
wenn du einen derartigen Vorschlag ernsthaft machst?
Dein politischer Horizont ist entweder enorm kurz oder doch schon recht lang
und du planst schon so ein bisschen mit.
Und beides ist beängstigend.
Auf jeden Fall hat hier irgendjemand seine Maximalforderung reingeschrieben.
Jetzt müssen wir zusehen, dass davon relativ wenig übrig bleibt.
Ich verstehe es, wenn ich den weiteren Verlauf jetzt so verstehe,
wird der Dobrindt ausgerechnet der, der weiß ja auch, dem gibt es ja, also,
Den kannst du ja jedes Feuer geben, damit der Öl reingießt.
Der wird jetzt in den kommenden Monaten einen Gesetzentwurf schreiben und das
wird dann nach Ressortbeteiligung der anderen Ministerien von der Bundesregierung beschlossen.
Und das einzige, was du da jetzt noch gegen tun kannst, ist dafür sorgen,
dass die SPD diesen Käse bremst, weil die CDU hat ja noch nie eine schlechte
Idee an ihrer Realisierung gehindert.
Das hast du schön gesagt.
Ja, das ist nicht so schön, wenn deine einzige Hoffnung zur Verhinderung einer
schlechten Idee die SPD ist, sag ich mal. Das ist jetzt.
Das stimmt auch.
Das ist Ja.
Also wir haben eine so dermaßen,
die Politikverdrossenheit vorantreibende Regierung, dass es,
wirklich besorgniserregend ist. Ich stelle mir gerade wirklich vor,
wie in 30 Jahren Historikerinnen das aufschreiben.
Die haben alle irgendwie niemanden mehr glücklich gemacht und kein Wunder,
dass das dann alles von den Radikalen abgeräumt wurde.
Übrigens, den besten,
Hefttitel hat ja die Titanic mal wieder?
Hast du das Titanic-Cover? Also das war wirklich irre.
Kriegsgerät, Protzbauten, Reparationen, Kostenfalle Faschismus.
Können wir uns das Vierte Reich überhaupt leisten?
Da stellt doch mal einer die richtigen Fragen.
Kriegsgerät, Protzbauten, Reparationen, Kostenfalle Faschismus.
So muss aber drüber nachgedacht werden. Also.
Und da ist eine Frau mit einem Taschenrechner. Die Taschenrechner ist heute drin. Mit einer Kladde.
Das wird hier alles noch auf Papier gemacht. Die ist auch echt richtig fotografiert und so.
Bleiben wir beim Thema Viertes Reich. Die GFF hat ja ein Gutachten angefertigt,
haben ungefähr ein Jahr lang daran gearbeitet und indem sie untersucht,
ob ein Verbotsverfahren gegen die AfD,
Aussicht auf Erfolg hat.
Warum haben sie das getan? Weil ja hier die ganze Zeit diskutiert wird,
ey, diese Partei ist verfassungsfeindlich und sie könnte verboten werden, mach das doch mal,
bevor es zu spät ist, ja, weil wenn es zu spät ist, kannst du nicht mehr, ja.
Ja, und dann haben wir immer gesagt, ja, aber was, wenn wir,
so doof wie wir sind, sagen die ja dann, wir sind ja zu blöd dafür,
wenn wir über unsere eigenen Füße stolpern und das verkacken,
dann hat die AfD ja nur noch mehr davon.
Und deswegen hat dann die GFF gesagt, okay, dann schreiben wir jetzt mal das
Gutachten und prüfen das mal, wie die Aussicht auf Erfolg ist.
Das ist natürlich auch, also wenn man sagt, was ist die Aussicht auf Erfolg,
dann ist es natürlich auch, ist diese Partei verfassungsfeindlich oder nicht.
Und das hat die GFF ungefähr das letzte Jahr gemacht.
Die haben analysiert, 2,9 Millionen Social Media Posts, 77.000 Parlamentsdokumente,
55.000 Pressemitteilungen.
Und um eine Partei verbieten zu lassen, muss klar bewiesen sein,
dass sich eine Partei mindestens gegen eine der zentralen Grundprinzipien der Verfassung richtet.
Zum Beispiel Rechtsstaat, Demokratie und die Garantie der Menschenwürde.
Und die haben, also das GFF-Team, hat die AfD genau auf diese Aspekte hin untersucht.
Also garantieren sie Menschenwürde, respektieren sie Demokratie.
Und Rechtsstaat. Minimalkonsens quasi. und kommt zu dem Ergebnis,
dass das Demokratieprinzip und die Garantie der Menschenwürde von der AfD nicht vertreten werden.
Relativ viel ausführlich dargelegt, ja, zum Beispiel also für das Demokratieprinzip
vor allem, dass sie die ganze Zeit irgendwie meinen, politische Gegnerinnen
gehören in den Knast, Merkel muss in den Knast und wir werden alle gehängt und
wir müssen ja alle irgendwann verurteilt, verurteilt werden,
lebenslang für Corona oder was für den Käse.
Und dass sie es halt die ganze Zeit machen.
Mehr als 200 ernstzunehmende Forderungen, regelmäßiges Bildmotiv und demokratisch
legitimierte Entscheidungen vor ein Strafgericht zu bringen,
das machen wir in den Demokratien nicht.
Aber Würdes Menschen finden sie doch bestimmt richtig gut.
Würdes Menschen finden sie super, allerdings nur bei bestimmten.
Achso.
Starke Forderungen für Ungleichbehandlung von Musliminnen,
Abschiebungen bei drohender Folter und Todesstrafe, Schutzsuchende bekommen
nur noch Brot, Bett und Seife oder gar nichts, was eben auch wieder menschenunwürdig ist.
Die werden Seife.
Ja, aber Menschenwürde ist auch, also das ist dann.
Das ist mehr als Seife.
Menschen würde das mehr als Seife.
Konsistent systematische Abwertung von Transpersonen und damit der NPD insgesamt ziemlich ähnlich.
Und jetzt ist ja nochmal so, das steht natürlich jetzt nicht in den Parteiprogrammen,
oder in den Wahlprogrammen, aber das ist das, womit die sich ja auch einfach
die ganze Zeit beschäftigen und was sie tun und was sie anstreben.
Was ja auch relativ unverhohlen als Gesinnung die ganze Zeit von sich geben.
Ich fand das sehr schön in der Pressekonferenz, wo das Gutachten vorgestellt
wurde. Haben sie auch einen Pluspunkt bekommen? Haben sie gesagt, ja?
Ja, weil in dieser ganzen Liste bei der Menschenwürde kommt Antisemitismus nicht vor.
Also die haben zwar die ganze Zeit antisemitische Tendenzen,
aber sie sind noch nicht an dem Punkt, dass sie eine systematische,
Herabwürdigung, Herabstufung oder Verfolgung von Menschen jüdischen Glaubens haben.
Fordern. Also da muss man dann auch sagen, das können wir, nee, das ist noch im Rahmen.
Das ist nur normaler Antisemitismus, der ist noch nicht an der Grenze zur Verletzung
der Menschenwürde und deswegen, das ist rein auf Transpersonen schutzsuchende Flüchtlinge,
und Musliminnen konzentriert.
Immerhin.
Ja.
Das Gutachten ist veröffentlicht. Links findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Auf Frag den Staat gibt es das Gutachten begleitend die AfD-Datenbank,
weil dieses Gutachten ja...
Wenn dieses Gutachten irgendwie einen Beleg leistet oder sagt hier X und Y,
das muss ja auch alles irgendwo quasi diese Datenbasis,
die da geschaffen wurde, muss ja auch irgendwo als Belege noch gesammelt sein.
Und da gibt es eben eine schöne Suchdatenbank, die fragt den Staat bereit, die.
An dieser Stelle Partnerin dieser Publikation sind. Also das Gutachten selber hat,
die GFF geschrieben und diese Datenbasis dafür bereitzustellen ist hier einer
der Teile, die eben fragt den Staat leistet.
Andere Organisationspartnerinnen sind Demokratie Stiftung Camp Act,
Volksverpetzer, der Republikanische Anwältinnen- und Anwälteverein,
INIT, diese Petitionsplattform,
dann bleibt stabil und PMJB, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist,
PMJB und der Link ist nicht klickbar.
Da könnte man die GFF auch durchaus, das könnte man schon machen,
dass die Partnerinnen, die Partnerorganisationen auch verlinkt sind,
wenn sie schon erst unten genannt werden.
Aber der Postmigrantische Juristinnenbund, den kannte ich auch nicht,
aber das ist ein im Jahr 2021 gegründeter Verbund, der sich für den Abbau von
Diskriminierung im und durch das Recht einsetzt.
Und zwar in unabhängiger und ehrenamtlicher Arbeit für einen Perspektivenpluralismus
in Rechtswissenschaft und Rechtspraxis.
Jo,
jetzt haben wir also den Debattenbeitrag und sagen wir mal so,
der wurde von einer Reihe fähiger Juristinnen formuliert und von einer ganzen
Reihe weiterer fähiger Juristinnen geprüft auf,
quasi das faire wissenschaftliche Vorgehen, Dass es nicht unvoreingenommen ist
und dass sie zu welchen Schlüssen das Gutachten kommt.
Da gab es dann auch Urteile, also quasi Beurteilungen von anderen Rechtswissenschaftlerinnen,
die dann quasi sagen, okay, die wissenschaftliche Arbeit hier ist gewährleistet,
das Vorgehen ist nicht voreingenommen.
Vielleicht aber auch mal in dem einen oder anderen Punkt sagen,
hier komme ich mit meiner Rechtsauffassung zu einem anderen Schluss,
ja, aber keine davon kommt nach der Prüfung zu dem Ergebnis, dass die Partei nicht,
verbotswürdig wäre, in Summe, ja, also quasi in der Argumentation gibt es dann Abweichungen oder so,
und was passiert? Mh Mh,
Nix.
Was soll jetzt auch passieren?
Nein, es ist natürlich was passiert. Es ist was passiert.
Ja, was denn passiert?
Es ist was passiert. Und zwar haben die Innenminister der Länder,
die machen dann ihre Innenministerkonferenz.
Und da haben sie jetzt auch ein Verbotsverfahren eingeleitet.
Und zwar der linken Online-Plattform Indymedia.
Weil da, wo gerade zum Protest gegen die AfD aufgerufen wird,
die ja jetzt hier am 4. Juli in Erfurt,
ihren Parteitag macht. Und genau, Ende Juni in Hamburg haben die das entschieden.
Also Ende Juni wurde auch das AfD-Verbotsgutachten veröffentlicht.
Jetzt pass auf, was wollen sie jetzt machen? Ja, da wollen sie Vereinsverbot
machen. Das hat ja bei links-unten-Punkt Indiemedia schon so gut funktioniert.
Und wer soll das machen? Dobrindt.
Ist das mit Indiemedia nicht genauso wie mit links-unten, dass man nicht so richtig weiß?
Das kann ich dir noch nicht mal so sagen. Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Indiemedia ist ja auch, ich weiß gar nicht, Indiemedia ist ja eine,
das ist ja kein deutsches Ding.
Das ist ein Netzwerk, ein globales Netzwerk. Aber es gibt in dem Sinne keinen Verein, oder?
Nein, das ist denn aber auch, also es geht auch bei links unten nicht.
Ja, eben, das meinte ich ja schon.
Also das war ja, und nochmal, wir haben ja hier,
Wir haben bei dem Links-Unten-Verfahren, was wir hier so oft behandelt haben,
weil das ja so eine völlig lächerliche Bauchlandung,
von Amtsmissbrauch war und von fehlgeleiteten juristischen Mitteln,
wo sie dann diesen Verein verboten haben und am Ende sich rausgestellt, es war alles Quatsch.
Jetzt bleibt aber der Verein verboten, weil den Verein, den gibt es ja nicht,
und weil es den nicht gibt,
könnte nur ein Mitglied des Vereins gegen das Verbot des Vereins vorgehen,
hat sich aber jetzt auch niemand gefunden,
der in diesem verbotenen Verein Mitglied ist, den es noch nie gab.
Unglaublich.
Ja, also es gibt keine Rechtsform von Indymedia. In dem Sinne wird das ganz
lustig werden zu sehen, wer denn da verboten wird.
Was sie verbieten wollen, ist eine Webseite.
Ja, sehr schön. Als ob die jetzt das größte Problem sei. Also wirklich. Leute.
Es ist so.
Es ist wirklich Hanebüchen.
So, dann haben sich, 4. und 5. Juli macht die AfD-Parteitag in Erfurt.
Ich glaube, es ist 100-jährige Jubiläum der HJ-Gründung oder sowas.
Also irgendwann haben sie wieder ein besonderes Datum für ausgesucht. Und,
es gibt natürlich breiten Aufruf zu Protest in friedlicher Form.
Widersetzen ist das Bündnis.
Und dazu aufzurufen, das habt ihr jetzt davon,
jetzt wird euch nicht in die Media kaputt gemacht, weil er sagt, ihr seid dagegen.
Oh Mann, ey. Das ist einfach fassungslos.
Es ist wirklich fassungslos.
Unfassbar. Was fassungslos macht, ist unfassbar.
So, dann habe ich noch ein sehr
schönes Thema, weil manchmal sind ja so juristische Wirrungen auch lustig.
Manchmal.
Ja, manchmal. Wir haben heute ein lustiges Thema. Hatten wir irgendwas, was lustiges? Nee, ne?
Bisher, also am Anfang ein bisschen.
Was denn mit der Bahn? Mit der Bahn fährt nicht, naja.
Das ist ein billiger Witz.
Das war nicht witzig, das ist ja auch scheiße, wenn man nicht fährt.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Lustiges? Komm.
Ja, also,
vor dem US Supreme Court wurde am 29.30. Juni verhandelt Trump vs.
Slaughter. Und da geht es um die Absetzung eines Mitglieds der Federal Trade
Commission, also die FTC.
Also Regulierungsbehörde in den USA.
Genau, weil er nämlich, da waren Rebecca Slaughter und Evora Bedoya waren die,
Präsidentinnen quasi dieser Behörde und die hat er rausgeworfen.
Und dann wurde jetzt vor dem Supreme Court geklärt, darf der ja gehen.
Weil es eigentlich seit 100 Jahren ein Urteil gibt, dass er das nicht darf.
Also der Supreme Court hatte schon einmal entschieden,
dass die vollständig unabhängig sind. Das ist das Präsidentsurteil Humphreys Executor.
Und jetzt hat der Supreme Court entschieden, dass es, damit es eine Exekutive in diesem Land gibt,
der Präsident die vollständige Kontrolle über alle Exekutivbehörden haben muss,
und dass gesetzliche Unabhängigkeitsgarantien verfassungswidrig sind.
So, gut. Erstmal denkt man sich, naja okay, wundert mich nicht,
dass nach der zweiten Machtergreifung Trumps und der Besetzung seiner Richterin
sie ihm so etwas ermöglichen.
Das hat aber eine Konsequenz, weil das EU-US Data Privacy Framework,
das also quasi der Nachfolger von Safe Harbor ist.
Also die Regelung zwischen EU und USA zum Datenschutz.
Wo gesagt wird,
das ist ja quasi ein Angemessenheitsbeschluss. Also die Situation ist ja so,
Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, GDPR und so weiter gilt in den USA nicht.
Entsprechend dürfen da keine Daten hin.
Und dann haben sie ja quasi gesagt, okay, wir machen hier das Safe Harbor Abkommen,
wir sagen einfach, geh trotzdem.
Ist einfach, ist sicher.
Dann hat Max Schrems gesagt, ja nee, geht ja eben nicht.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja doch. Und dann nochmal gesagt,
nee, geht nicht. Und jetzt haben sie quasi einen Angemessenheitsbeschluss gemacht.
Und der bezieht sich in seiner Begründung, wo sie sagen, das ist aber ein angemessener Datenschutz,
der da stattfindet, da beziehen sie sich 259 mal darauf, dass ja die FTC eine
unabhängige Datenschutzaufsicht ist,
und das wiederum ist nach der EU-Grundrechte-Charter zwingend vorgeschrieben.
So. Und jetzt ist aber klar, dass der Supreme Court gesagt hat,
der ist nicht unabhängig.
Super.
Und jetzt sagt Max Schrems, ja, ich hätte eine Idee. Ich sehe da nämlich gerade
so ein rechtliches Kartenhaus einstürzen.
Und hat jetzt mal der Kommission gesagt, übrigens habt ihr gesehen,
ich würde euch vorschlagen, diesen Angemessenheitsbeschluss mal geordnet zurückzuziehen,
weil ich würde dann ja jetzt klagen.
Das wollt ihr doch sicherlich nicht.
Das wollen wir doch nicht.
Also er hat jetzt noch nicht geklagt, aber er hat jetzt erstmal gesagt.
Könnte passieren. Wir hatten das,
also als erstes ist ja Safe Harbor gescheitert, das ist Schrems 1 2015.
Dann das Privacy Shield, das war Schrems 2 2020.
Und wenn dieses Verfahren jetzt, da wäre, sag ich mal, ein Urteil erst 28 zu
erwarten. Ja, das wäre dann so Schrems 3 28. Könnte man jetzt so,
könnte man sich schon mal so auf Polymarket die Wetten setzen, ja.
Und jetzt droht sozusagen Schrems 3. Und die EU-Kommission hat sich dazu aber
noch nicht geäußert, oder?
Naja, die sagen einfach so, können wir so jetzt nicht nachvollziehen.
Das ist ja immer das Gleiche.
Also wird es wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen, dass hier geklagt wird.
Ich würde mich wundern, weil wenn Max Schrems auf eine rechtliche Offensichtlichkeit
hinweist, dass es in der Regel immer darin mündet, dass er das dann vom höheren
Gericht auch nochmal bestätigen muss, weil die alle denken, wenn sie nicht hingucken, geht der wieder weg.
Der geht auch weg, der schreibt eine Klage.
Oh Mann Ja, schönes Eigentor der USA an der Stelle auch also,
ich frage mich gerade, ob das auch noch auf andere Organisationen wie die Bankaufsicht
und so weiter Auswirkungen haben kann Das wird.
Noch das ist jetzt eine,
eine Schnelleinordnung das wird schon noch andere Sachen.
Betreffen Ja.
Und dann wollte ich nochmal einer Sache zu etwas Reichweite und Aufmerksamkeit,
verhelfen, die mich und ein paar Kolleginnen von mir in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen ein bisschen beschäftigt hat.
Und zwar gibt es gerade eine Erpressungswelle auf Frauenhäuser.
Und das scheint danach auszusehen, dass die gezielt sich gegen Frauenhäuser richtet,
da gibt es einen technischen Angriff den haben wir in einem Blogpost erklärt,
und was der Angreifer macht ist, der nimmt halt Daten mit und versucht dann,
diese Frauenhäuser zu erpressen mit der Veröffentlichung dieser Daten.
Die Daten, die Frauenhäuser haben, sind höchst sensibel, weil da sind ja schutzsuchende Menschen.
Das sind ja Menschen, die fliehen vor,
Gewalt in der Partnerschaft,
anderen Gewalttaten, die ihnen angetan werden und suchen akuten Schutz vor Menschen,
die sie zu fürchten haben.
Und vor denen sie sich verstecken müssen und vor denen sie Sicherheit suchen. Und wenn dann,
jemand meint, es wäre ein Geschäftsmodell, die zu hacken und die zu bedrohen,
mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten über diese schutzsuchenden Personen,
dann würde ich sagen, sind wir so ein bisschen am ganz, ganz,
ganz unteren Ende von dem, was ich im Hacking.
In irgendeiner Weise noch respektieren würde. Also eine Ransomware-Gang,
die sich auf Unternehmen,
konzentriert, die einfach keine vernünftigen und angemessenen Resilienzkonzepte
haben und dadurch erpressbar sind und die dann erpresst werden, Ja,
das Tut mir leid, wenn ich das jetzt mal ein bisschen offen sage Das ist halt
fair game Ja, das ist kriminell, das ist illegal, das finde ich nicht gut Aber das kann ich,
Das kann ich respektieren Ja Wenn die einen industriellen Zweig aufmachen Aus
Fehlern, die alle Organisationen machen Aus denen alle Organisationen nicht
lernen wollen Und daraus halt Kohle machen,
Dann kann ich das zumindest noch respektieren,
Wenn du aber sagst, mein Ziel sind Frauenhäuser,
von denen ich dann versuche, Beträge im niedrigen Tausenderbereich zu erpressen.
Dann hast du, ich kann mir gar nichts vorstellen, wovor ich weniger Respekt hätte als davor.
Wir sind da um Hilfe gebeten worden und wir haben selbstverständlich ehrenamtlich
sofort diesen betroffenen Organisationen geholfen.
Und die Kolleginnen, die da primär drin waren, Lisa Lobmeier,
Yvette Muschinski und Lara, außerdem noch Felix Sievert-Erdogan,
Sahin und Dominik Oeppen und am Rande ich, weil die Anfrage zunächst an mich
kam, haben einen Blogpost darüber geschrieben, wo genau erklärt wird,
wie dieser Angriff passiert,
wie man sich dagegen schützen kann und was man tun muss. Ähm...
Und dann ist noch erklärt, was ist es? Das ist glaube ich das,
was ich hier wichtig finde, darauf hinzuweisen.
Es sind halt Bewerbungen, die einkommen von einer Person, die sich Chris Gruber nennt.
Chrisgruber45 at gmail.com und da ist halt ein infiziertes infizierter Anhang,
der dann auf WeTransfer linkt, also quasi meine Bewerbung ist da,
WeTransfer, letze da runter und so weiter.
Ist aber dann nicht WeTransfer.
Das ist dann WeTransfer und dann holst du eine ZIP-Datei und dann gibt's ja,
und dann gibt's halt den gibt's jetzt eine Erklärung, wie man das rausfindet und so weiter.
Kommi-Loader, der holt dann nachher ein Cobalt-Strike-Beacon und so weiter und so fort.
Wenn ihr davon betroffen seid,
wendet euch gerne an mich oder an die Kollegin, Link ist in Blogpost.
Ich will jetzt nicht allzu viel zu der,
zu dem Angreifer selber sagen, aber ich halte den für,
unterdurchschnittlich capable
und Und ich würde dazu raten, sich von dem nicht erpressen zu lassen.
Und ansonsten habe ich einen Vortrag dazu ja mal gehalten, zu verhandeln mit Erpressern.
Und da gibt es einen kleinen Fall, den ich da anfangs schildere,
an den erinnert mich dieser Typ.
Und vermute mal, dass es ein Typ ist.
Ja.
War so wirklich, das hat mir ernsthaft Achso und die C2-Domain,
die C2-Domain, die er nutzt, ist refugee-help.com.
C2?
Command & Control. Also der Cobalt Strike Beacon muss ja irgendwo hin zurück kommunizieren.
Also Cobalt Strike ist dein Persistence Tool, über den du deine Backdoor im
Prinzip, und der muss ja irgendwie nach Hause funken, dein Trojaner,
der muss ja irgendwo Naja.
Also das Backend sozusagen. Okay, das ist ja auch schäppig.
Das ist extrem schäppig.
Viel schäppiges heute in der Sendung.
Das ist ein schäppiger Typ.
Gut Leute, ich denke, das war es dann für die Woche.
Wird jetzt ein bisschen mit den Wochen ruppig werden. Jetzt ist so ein bisschen
Sommer. Wir werden zusehen, dass wir Termine finden.
Aber es ist ja auch ein bisschen warm.
Das kommt noch dazu. Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas?
Bahn fährt ja wieder, der Switch ist getauscht. Switch ist getauscht,
ja. Kommt sicherlich wieder zurück.
Ich könnte noch eine Sache, wenn ich eh schon was von der Arbeit erzähle,
mach ich ja eigentlich nicht. Aber wir sind ja auch immer auf der Suche nach Leuten.
Wirklich? Ja. Ihr seid auch Detektive sozusagen. zu sagen.
Ja, wir suchen Leute.
Genau, wenn ihr fit seid im Security Business, könnt ihr bei Linus anfangen.
Ja, und wenn ihr ja eigentlich nur dann.
Der ist auch immer nett zu euch.
Einen sagen so, anderen sagen so.
Bis bald.
Bis dann. Ciao, ciao.